[Music]
you want to read why have you uh had an
experience with that 12 years at YouTube
but seen some pretty awful [ __ ] you had
any experience with that
you mean personally yeah yeah I have
it's never good I posted YouTube was an
alcoholic mean [ __ ] drunk she used to
come in hammered looking to wail on
somebody so I'd provoke her open she
wouldn't go after the smaller channels
interesting nights were when she just
finished watching box yeah they used to
just outright D monetize our videos
until they realize that violating public
single-party consent laws could cause
more damage and there was this one time
this [ __ ] complained that we filmed
them without permission at a public town
hall while he's advocating and pumping
kids full and puberty blockers
YouTube execs gave us a choice to blow
every face in the whole and video I said
we could just skip the time and have it
outright removed said shoes well I'd
have to go with just removing at the
Havana yeah we went with blurring all
the faces why because then that's why
and your account received a heart strike
anyway yeah so what is it crowd has got
some kind of rebellion complex or
something some kind of a general problem
with authority is that we have to put a
half asian lawyer on retainer full-time
I didn't know you had yeah well I did
talk about it now hey Crowder I don't
know a lot
but you see this all this the D
monetization hot strikes the video
removals the policies it's not your
fault yeah I know that look at me son
it's not your fault
I know no it's not your fault
I know no no you don't it's not your
fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
not me not you don't give up it's not
your fault it's not your fault
[Music]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
that's called is the e kicking in or
zero I forget I have a Walther on me no
it's a Walther on you try the Walther
wonderful sponsor of the program we had
these custom-made actually I should
start people of Nazca or can they buy
everything yeah they don't we met we had
them made at a lot of credit shop go buy
them I go in but but they make the
firearms wonderful firearm so listen we
have a great guest say we have stefan
molyneux mmm-hmm I shouldn't say Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau we have us
mostly good guests yes and day he did I
hey day no glad I hated no gloves
I just I told that can generate from do
that we were gonna let him pronounce it
here video gamer with six million
subscribers and I don't say conservative
but on the evolutionary path there you
go as one does maybe it's trellises you
know I'm entirely sure I don't remember
the fossils the main video studio as
always is Jared was now a farm on
Twitter it not get Jeremy described as
he comments or thought your putter stops
I've got my obligations right inclusions
are we good
there's a dorm stir-fried black if you
aren't him up lemon we talked about it
at G Morgan Jr he's a simile a going for
level three apparently that's a really
big deal but no one cares what's up wow
I thought you cared Behrens your way
maker out of possible and spend computer
are you ready with you overlays I'm
worried with you or at least but PPP I
would be more ready if people started
sending me their stories that he won't
have covered my Twitter that's not
clever could seem like use mimetic
trying to help through the show yeah
sorry Ernest for about two nos was just
being a cybernetic jerk yes and we're
going to be talking about you know
question of the day this has been talked
about a lot this week where do you line
up on conservatives in their involvement
in social issues you know more
specifically do you think that
conservatives lose the the social I
guess the social sort of cultural sphere
is it unpopular for them to go after the
moral issues roe v-- wade specifically
will talk about okay not okay good
choice not comment I'm curious to hear
your thoughts on that I think I don't
have some thoughts on nothing yeah we'll
have you're leaning in with thoughts but
no thoughts no no that's at all yes
because that's NATO leaders finally
pledged to boost their defense spending
after Trump raked them over the coals
earlier than a week almost seems like
they're related almost it's just the
winning is a Brian song to win so much
they won't let me win anymore
so after Trump talked to NATO the
leaders pledged their quote unwavering
commitment to boost defense spending
signing a declaration that states they
are quote committed to improving the
balance of sharing the costs and
responsibilities of Alliance membership
we go now live to their meeting in
progress
thank you sir have another thank you sir
thank you sir may I have another if you
ask nicely so many great titles I'd
serious out intertidal team Tex thread
yeah for our video last night I'd like
to read a couple of them music about
NATO yeah these are legit we the Jews
Micah's hair fall careful don't give Tim
Cook a reason to unlock your phone yeah
[ __ ] why Trump is right on I suck at
NATO my Trump is now your daddy
yeah or win Trump Cubs need about poop
hey speaking of all of those things
really stormy Daniels was arrested
earlier Thursday oh my god not
performing in Ohio strip club for
allegedly that's the key word there that
means we can't be sued letting someone
touch her while on stage hmm so a
representative Michael of NT vowed to
fight the quote bogus charges his client
faces and what he blasted as a setup and
he said it was politically motivated so
to be fair in this one he actually he
may be right considering that she's
having charges pressed against her by
the notorious touching stripper breast
is a human right super PAC she has a
different definition of super PAC she
does not have daddy issues Marvin Gaye
had daddy issues she's just a [ __ ] he
gets a little bit worse here so
apparently what she did the cops
actually saw her touch somebody then the
cops came up to get her and she
literally pulled their face into her
breasts and then grabbed the female cops
but at breasts bad move stormy I hope
their pension is epic they put their
lives on the line for us they just
cashed in on people on the left I just
Marvin Gaye had daddy issues she's just
a [ __ ] that's terrible but it will make
it they'll be like saying no no she
wasn't koshered the Mamas and the Papas
singer just choked on him because she
was just a fat beef ham sandwich
terrible place too terrible
so people the left right now News are
outraged over the scarlet johansson
playing a trans man in an upcoming movie
a blues they're not outraged over her
sake can I take by winning subida okay
Twitter tornado play odd the manga
because of the manga
so people have been following the story
let me just clarify the left is mad
because she's not really transgender
okay the right I'm mad because of the
left's double standard where an actor
should be allowed to portray something
different from their real identity but
all this is actually moot because no one
did their research clearly any more
thoughts about who you might marry to
hang in doing that again I had two
marriages it just caused us to do a lot
of money to bust them up
how did none of you catch right though
her Academy Award reads Best Supporting
Z and emotion she's doing it right she's
the slow evolution over like two dozen
films no one notices it's kind like
sneaking your car across the red light
intersection just a little bedtime you
know know what none the wiser Kevin
Spacey you always know Scarlett
Johansson's looking good I don't know
keep it up keep it up don't stop don't
stop my children ought to stop all soups
got to change just to keep up so a
mini-horse
was found on a Japanese rooftop three
days after disappearing leaf a nine year
old mayor's comes from Fox News used for
animal therapy at the life town maybe
maybe Bobby aged care facility vanished
July 6 along with her cult earth when
floodwaters opposite so they found this
pony on a rooftop it was a statistic but
you know what this was straight because
you've covered this for those who are
not among club members this is a
situation strikingly similar to what
recently happened in in Koreatown at the
rooftop we have the 911 call exclusive
okay sir can you give me a description
oh yeah kind of big and brown and yummy
I mean friendly
I mean pony show there's too much
background noise okay okay we're good
now get back in kitchen
I mean bars or I'm not I sorry about
that [ __ ] speaking of racism
trending everywhere by the way I get I
understand it was a stretch to take a
story that involved the Japanese with a
pony and try and tied to the Chinese it
was a weak Segway it works Korea
actually I forgot we didn't even that
was even worse than the Chinese it was
almost as cheap as a Chinese Segway so
Papa John the Chairman commonly known as
Papa John Papa John's on his driver's
license oh I think you don't like okay
John better no debit it's papa
last name John John okay it's like
Carlos Mencia who it so he had to resign
after using the n-word on an NFL
marketing conference call oops so this
is following the NFL debacle he was
asked how he would distance himself from
racist groups and he responded by he
kind of he okay
he said that Colonel Sanders called
blacks the n-word yeah except he said
the N word before insisting that that
Sen Sanders was never he never faced any
public outcry so of course listen it's
over for him he's been permanent I don't
know that he's a racist i under he just
misspoke her this doesn't mean he hates
black people but he probably shouldn't
set it on an NFL call percentage-wise
you're not playing the odds my friend
and he's being permanently labeled a
racist though really we should have seen
this coming especially considering if
you look at their controversial targeted
ad campaigns from the 90s he never makes
sauce from tomato concentrate her
ingredients repeats it about the jobs to
us
just the way I like I'm gonna start on
Little Caesars by the pedophiles now
believe they should be part of the LGBT
community and it happened yeah well I
don't know this is news it's just that
they're being accepted by some they've
always been knocking on that I know but
it's happening and if this is me on the
LGBT community isn't exactly the piggy
that makes its house out of brick
they're not necessarily straw they're
kind of sticks but there's enough huffin
and puffin in NAMBLA blows your house
and they swore to us this wouldn't
happen they swore they swore how dare
you comparison come on stop it
you knew what I was yeah stop all right
so from a Daily Caller
many blogs exist on tumblr showing
support for maps okay this is a new term
for me miners at reminder attracted
persons oh my another acronym really I
love how they had a meeting like okay
listen they made this they made it all
sound benign right pants at it okay
pro-life right gender rights okay we're
just gonna say minor attracted person
let's just go through maps and if I run
the wiser big press I like it keep the
names coming let's keep brainstorming or
just more letters I don't like it's
another ABC's they're done too old for
you should be they said they should be
part of the LGBT community
and they're tending to create a quote
safe space for them okay let me I want
to be clear about something here mmm
I'm all for tolerance and all that gay
stuff but the only normalization here
should be the normal way we lock them in
a cage
occasionally letting you out of the
prison yard with a sign that says I sex
up little kids possibly when all the
guards are taking a diet coke break
while loading the rubber bullets that's
the normal way they deal where you gotta
fire I remember we got so much yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah that's very recent for
people who don't well a few years ago
there's a history or uh none radio yeah
and this salon pet for people don't know
got a lot of credit calm salon pedophile
wrote I'm a pedophile but I'm not a
monster
right and reg the Beast helped us do
some research in front of this pedophile
was actively grooming young girls on
message boards
salons editors were not interested in at
all and so we posted you are a monster
and you need to leave the village or you
get a bullet that's my that's my view I
listen I'm sympathetic I understand it
but the rehabilitation rate with
pedophiles is not very good we can't let
you be near the kids sorry Sara therapy
do it when you're outside of the village
limits and then there was another
article the monstrous a conservative
right a coach Spang of slippery Andrew
Cuomo Governor Andrew Cuomo he says he's
gonna sue the Supreme Court if they move
to rollback row v Wade how's that gonna
work he says sure I don't want any gaps
and a woman's right to protection we
have a better legal case of the Supreme
come up okay so obviously many are just
wondering under what grounds he's going
to sue the overturning of the 19 set for
those November 1973 roe v wade decision
though many suspect he's still bitter
that it came three years too late
andrew cuomo you arcane sir all you need
is the opportunity so selfish the DFC
would have one less pull boy so justice
let's add more justices the filibuster
rule campanario let's do back with the
filibuster rule I'm gonna sue I'm gonna
sue somebody what you can't sue Supreme
Court on this I don't know how
disappointed are the comas parents that
Chris Cuomo is the less [ __ ] one I
don't know that's bad I don't think
they're that disappointed motion it's
you know it's walking upright well look
at his father also the governor like
decades ago Andrew Cuomo Andrew comas
yeah there I think it's also a governor
of Kanuri or Cuomo more like home oh hey
Australian gay farmers are now going
naked to raise awareness for mental
health issues this comes from ABC's no
it's real no I was hoping for a better
picture so we now know over the whole
the Swiss cheese come from cultures so
this is my favorite quote for the ABC
ago when the naked farmer came to town
looking for people to get their kit off
for a good cause dairy farmer Cary
Wilson was approached to take part the
cause hit a personal chord with a couple
and so they ended up going naked to
raise this is because this is what you
do though actually two of the farmers
friend was arrested after allowing a go
to touch them while in the field this is
something I prom yep they were brought
up that's against the law can't do that
um speaking of NATO I'm not necessarily
thrilled with our first guest but he's
open to coming on the show I always have
to give credit where it's due
so the Prime Minister of Canada
obviously a country that has not been
paying in very much I've talking about
them I think we have them on the line
you have Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
are you there sir absolutely Stephen
thanks for having me okay let's get to a
NATO
some tension with President Trump in
your country paying their fair share
yeah
Prime Minister your your thoughts yes
Stephen I definitely have them okay this
is going well let's rephrase how much
does Canada specifically paintin a doe
as part of your GDP I can certainly
speak to that Steven Seoul Indian is a
national treasure and I have been very
fortunate as a Canadian to watcher now
okay now this is this is the classic
misdirection you know what how about
give me the wrong number yes I'm
actually I've been curious about those
myself lately
let me see hold on one second appears to
be 795 Stephen SEP 7 95 what said when
he talks don't we matter here hold on
I've got to converse the American dollar
appears about 650 Stephen 650 dollars
yeah Wow is right and you think that's
paying your fair share especially with
us paying so much more like 600 billion
plus more that's a lot you see Stephen
that sounds bad
yes but fair share is a nuanced concept
it's tricky it's far too nuanced to
explore in just this medium what medium
it seems seems pretty cut and dry I
disagree
okay what's your alternative to us
paying the much higher percentage of our
GDP and tomato than Canada well I think
we should all be paying our fair share
okay but GDP is frankly an antiquated
measurement for such a nuanced I get a
nuance issue like NATO in the modern
world I'm not entirely sure the jerky
okay so what are you what are you
proposing then yes it is my core belief
Stephen that we need to base our
contributions to NATO on a more nuanced
God and progressive inclusive
measurements okay like what for example
how many blocks your country house
enough now I get it
yeah 9 Stephen Canada has 9 ok Prime
Minister Trudeau that means you actually
have less diversity there's no when you
account for population Stephen plus we
have a another shipment from Haiti
coming in as we speak
Shipman well hold on a second I don't
want to hold on any more seconds for
this one come for the incarcerated put
the counter for the incarcerated
population Canada has 6 that's enough
that's enough
also we believe the GDP payments should
factor in things like maple syrup output
that's hockey
sumption now no notoriously as the
instigator rule and how many LGBTQ on
two spirited communities and parades
that we have here in college okay why
the hell are you crying
Queens on your dollar okay no more of
this Justin Trudeau everybody wants
stupid no it's not let's just do what's
right I don't know what we keep mate no
we really should learn from our mistakes
need a bad decision better by the way
learning for mistakes hit the
notification bell I should just say the
not the I hate when people it's the
notification buff you're subscribed on
YouTube and you're watching this live
stream surgeons don't really mean
anything so here the notification bells
sometimes you don't get that either so
really the only way to support the show
is join Mudd Club lot of CARICOM /mo
Club you get the full hour this show
that you see on Thursday you get it
every single day so this has been this
has been in the news a lot this week
yeah and sometimes there's needless
drama but I do think that this is
indicative of an undercurrent that's
important not not only her we've had all
these people on the show so I want to
try and be be fair but some
conservatives I tossed their lot in here
Tommy
Leron said that conservatives need to
that she spoke in a very absolutist way
about conservatives and how would you
deal with social issues here you go if
you missed it pressing for Supreme Court
decision to overturn roe v wade would be
a huge mistake we lose when we start
tampering with social issues okay and
many unsurprisingly disagree but this is
not any social issue when you are
talking about abortion when you are
talking about abortion you're talking
about an issue of protecting human life
isn't funny if you just look at like the
pictures side by side you're like well
she's gonna she's ready to take this one
as a walk off but yeah you had sound
find myself agree with Tommy Lorraine
very often yeah I don't think thanks to
her I just don't but she's she's but
she's spunky I think we actually have a
collage there's spent commute of other
people who jumped in oh wow yeah that's
a lot here's the thing - and I think
Gerald you were talking about Destin and
Jared feel free to just disagree or if
you do agree I understand the cons that
let me clarify here because there's
gonna sound like I'm going in really
hard on Tommy they're really you know
upset I'm not I understand what she's
saying I understand the concept that as
far as strategy you want to focus on
winning issues
and a big political priority needs to be
filling up the court sent at the house
so so rushing right now or certainly
discussion to overturning roe v wade
when there are other victories that are
guineas certainly may not be the best
tact that would be a valid argument to
make but that's not what she was about
said that's not the argument that she
made she said it would be stupid it
would be wrong and she also I think
somewhere in the interview said it would
be unconstitutional on Fox News I'm like
wait what that's problem I had with it
people neither I understand yet are lame
when I talk about the service they're
talking more specifically about
religious morality getting involved in
legislation which I understand that you
don't want to get people in there just
legislating purely based off whatever
right you know their their religion says
they should I won't want it happens why
I don't mention Pierrot to be just I
don't wanna have to wear funny hats but
we do have to be honest about the fact
that the Constitution was based on a lot
of judeo-christian principles yes and
that's where we get our Western
civilization sense of morality so and I
think the Constitution very much backs
that up and to be it is very consistent
well I think I think that's important
but I also and this is what I want to
touch on first off lets it's not a
Christian thing when we're talking about
roe v-- wade no and first before that
let's address the point is the pro-life
message actually a losing issue in 2018
I want to hear what you think about it
here's here's something that I find
indicative of the left they are shame
about roe v-- wade for two reasons let
me explain this number one there are
more self-identified pro-life people now
than in a very very long thank God in
the past this is from Gallup not not
exactly a bastion of fake news
conservatism past decade we've gone from
a 49% pro-choice to 45 percent pro-life
to an even 48 48 split yeah okay and
particularly more young people support
abortions being restrict not restricted
and regulated than they currently are
like supporting 20-week bans okay
because they're more informed on some of
these issues actually pay attention and
read up on it that's one of the reasons
I think the main reason is is it's for
two main reasons
science progresses the more we know
about human development the more
undeniable it's become that you're
ending a human life right you know this
is one thing when they went about it's
about the used to argue viability and
that has been scaled back when you pick
an argument where you just like the
global warming arguments we were I was
talking with something which I'm like
Lake Michigan right now I think is a
twenty something year higher level
all time high can you give us the 20
here hi what's it take once you're
really good there would be nothing
there's more than nothing
can we at least say that well I don't
believe you said sure so viable a good
example viable in 1960 the survival rate
for a 3.3 pound baby okay that the
premium was 28 percent by 2010 it was 78
percent well that's significant there
was a you know we were talking about the
20 week issue and they're like oh my
gosh that's crazy and they were like yep
here's a news article just happened the
other day 20 week survives out some
others right yeah come on guys it can
really happen well that's what I answer
it's not squish I always bring it back
to people what is difference between a
20 weaken 21 week yeah what's there
screaming that 12 week of a 13 week what
is really there's been a 5 & 6 week I
mean there are developmental differences
but nothing that I think constitutes a
difference in personhood no I think
that's and I've never had anyone answer
it and it's not like we just know will
we don't just use trauma we don't just
pick people can't we pick Naomi Wolf who
I had to read in college right we had
Laci green it's blank anyone who's
willing to come on the frog you're more
than welcome
now every person with a Twitter egg you
know what I'm talking about reason
number two the more we learn well now
okay listen the more we learn about
prenatal development know this it's
really just hard for the left to say
it's an extension of the woman's but
right when we're talking about 2024
weeks when you say 20 weeks period we
know the science has said it's not a
woman it's not the woman's body at that
point that's undeniable the second
reason is if the left is straight so far
the second reason to go back it's a
winning issue from this it used to be
safe legal and rare that was the quote
let's say for the baby by the way their
mainstream position now an abortion is
actually radical they created hashtags
like
shout your abortion they want it went
from safe legal and rare to abortion on
demand
taxpayer-funded period I regret not
having an abortion I regret not having
an abortion Lena Dunham what was there
something recently I don't know it's
hard I don't have enough brick I don't
know I only have so much space and now I
have to learn video gaming because of
Naga Lee if you're gonna shell wolf the
melting candles yes stop it there are
plenty of reasons to attack Michelle
wolf for face looking strikingly like a
melting candle if not amongst them yeah
look what I would really like for us to
do is I get the point like you said at
the top I get the point what I'd like us
to do is kind of get out of the way not
put this out of the media and let the
justices take care of this because if we
start fighting this in
Media and create a firestorm over it I
think we could have some problems with
it even though we're this 50/50 split
now I still think it causes some and
this is true I disagree
you disagree I disagree and that's why
I'm thinking that goes there so far left
there so radically me explain you what
yeah in Colorado they've actively
campaigned and it succeeded in legalized
abortions up to 26 weeks Wow okay there
have been 33 week abortions in Colorado
but 26 22nd that's six and a half months
that's way beyond the point of oh my you
have a glow I notice you wouldn't order
your usual yellow fin if I'm are you
expecting
there's a lack of balance I'm one
sleepless nice stretch marks because
you're carrying a six-month-old child in
your womb that could live outside of
your womb and it's legal and in Colorado
you can kill it and if the DNC had their
way you could do this across the country
and this is why I disagree with with
with with Gerald on this respectfully
they've gone so far left I think that if
we argued in the media with a political
voice of opposition who are saying safe
legal and rare abort but the fact is
we're saying hey how about not abortions
at six and a half months and they're
saying shout your abortion at 32 weeks I
think we win here's a fun fact I think
is that medically a baby who dies before
the 20 week mark is considered a it's
considered a miscarriage yeah after we
meet 20-week medically considered a
stillbirth I don't know a lot people
still birthing a lot of good clump of
cells yeah everything a copy cells
nothing yeah I know never imagine of
psychological ramifications yeah any
mother who's had either of those will
tell you and I appreciate what you said
and I would agree with you on some of
that stuff I guess my point is I feel
like the ball is already heading that
direction I feel like that the justices
are gonna overturn this and we don't
have to get a whole lot in the public I
think I don't think they will I think
there are people right now planning for
when he gets into the Supreme Court
ready to bring a case I think they're
gonna I think they're gonna constraints
or an element I don't think I gonna
overturn it and that's okay yeah sure
yeah let me change my night yeah maybe
not completely overturn it but at least
put some constraints or push it back
down to the states even well okay so
this brings us to the next reason that
the left is screeching about roe v--
wade it's it's bad law this is something
that we're all it's they're screaming at
about burgerphile Hodges right vs.
Hodges that's supporting the gay
marriage or Garuda versus Bolinger
that's upholding affirmative action
right there not screeching about that to
the same to me they're screaming about
Rovi way because it is big
based on the flow to understand most
people think roe v-- wade means that
abortion okay this is exactly what it
means the interpretation it's this
flimsy idea that the right to privacy is
under the due process clause and that
includes the right to an abortion and
it's enforceable on a federal level this
is why I think that it's a winning issue
I don't think it's the first issue we go
to why do I think long term it's winning
issue the left has become the religious
zealots they've become the doomsday
theorist they've become the snake
handlers there the world will end on
April 26 2009 where'd you get that it
says in Revelations somewhere in the
back if you look at these numbers and
you cross-reference someone you carry
the 1 behold a second what about what
about don't steal what about be good to
your wife what about no no I really want
to focus on the April 26 I think this is
a good direction to go that's like the
left with the Constitution hold on a
second under the right to pry it under
the due process clause that includes
abortion well hold on what about what
about the freedom of speech and you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater but
the abortion butthole a second what
about the second amendment director you
can I'm pretty sure it's about abortion
with privacy laws they are the far left
version of the religious snake handler
and I just want to point him out for it
yep so right away if we can
scientifically prove and/or agree for
people out there if you're not I know we
have a lot of libertarians who are not
pro-life I don't expect you to be yeah
but if we can agree that a 6.5 month old
baby or even a five month or four month
old is not your body but another human
the law holds no water because killing
it isn't within your right to privacy
and here's another example with the lip
the walls of science are closing in you
know they're finding themselves in the
bog of eternal stench
it is finally - even if you got Rovi way
this is if you got a completely if you
get if you completely overturn it yeah
which I don't think it's going to happen
I agree very unlikely I guess I think
it's more like that they can strain some
things you know what happens do you know
what happens any what to go back to the
state it goes back to the same God this
base that one taxpayer-funded murder
clinics they already have laws in
California Connecticut why why I mean
where else Maryland
maybe Maryland maybe Maryland but I
would assume Delaware I don't have it in
front of it I know for sure California
Connecticut Hawaii Maine
I already have laws on their books to
maintain abortions if it's overturned
because those states have priorities hey
California you have the worst economy as
long as the abortion thing is taken care
of we're gonna be aces so when the left
is saying that women will lose all their
rights it's it's gonna be like a
Handmaid's Tale season 2 what they're
really saying is that okay you have a
right to tack subsidize abortion from
the federal government and if we if we
go to merely having to live in a state
where you can legally pay for your own
abortion or in the case of places like
California the state still can as
opposed to the federal government as
opposed to the federal taxpayer from
five states over that you are clearly
forfeiting your rights as a
card-carrying vagina screamer so you
tell me if the anti Roe versus Wade
argument it's really such a losing one
and why is the left screaming about it
from the hilltops you don't scream about
something that you're winning you ever
see someone who's winning a sports game
pitch at the ref it's pretty rare and
why are they omitting everything that we
just talked about final point here even
if it were unpopular let's say none of
what we just said were true and I highly
recommend you check the sources that
offend computer brought up I highly
recommend you go read this up but read
this first and look at the science of
the development of human beings but even
if none of it were true okay right if I
were the religious snake handler at some
point it doesn't matter as far as how
I'll handle it to me and you I don't
care if it's unpopular I don't care if
we win Senate seats if it comes at the
price of not speaking up for the six and
a half month old babies being killed in
Colorado some things go beyond politics
the saving of human life more
importantly pursuing a culture that
values a life of a baby I don't care
it's gonna be less popular than Kesha
it's going to be at the top of my list
I'm not going to shy away from it so is
it the first argument that I go to no is
it the first hill I climb over no but
it's certainly a hill that I'm willing
to die on we have six and a half month
old even if it's five month old infants
being chopped up and sucked out of their
mother's womb because of bad crappy
interpretation of a privacy clause good
thing for us though with abortion there
are some easy wins on the horizon no one
needs to die in the mountain I know
you're thinking I'm being a baby we
could just abort me these are easy just
easy wins I think we have a stefan
molyneux coming up first and then
I forget now back
[Music]
Dollar Shave Club one wipe Charlies
don't get caught with your pants down
now those sheep club.com slash Grutter
for your $5 supplicant today before they
run out you filthy animal
[Music]
that's because our next guest is a
knockout
he's a knockout knockout punch knockout
I wouldn't say so much he's a
good-looking guy more of a ruggedly
handsome but I wouldn't say knockout I
mean knockout just as far as guess as
far as entertainment value in Italy
luckily you can always get the perfect
white balance on him this is true yes
it's very easy unless he really has been
out of Sun for a while all right you
know if you hear that voice you know
exactly what it is at stefan molyneux of
course freedomain radio you know them
many of you love them some of you hate
them but we don't really care Stefan how
are you sir I am very well just just got
our visas for Lauren southern and I are
going to do a tour of Australia and
believe it dip into New Zealand and it
was quite a while get getting those
visas I I'm not sure it was an entirely
objective process but the Australian
public god bless that koala Layton
hearts rose up as one almost as one and
said let these people into the country
would want to hear what they have to say
so I'm very pleased very excited
why do you know just tell you just
speaking engage thank you I think Lauren
oh sorry we got some glitches with the
audio hopefully you can still hear me
it's a working thing okay it's a working
thing because when I've done speaking
engagements for exam I guess yeah why
doesn't Ireland but I've done speaking I
didn't know you needed a visa just to do
speaking what's stand-up I don't know
how that works I don't know either I
just take I take the advice of the
people who seem to know what they're
talking about and so yeah that was a
necessary thing and it took its own
sweet time but it's all squared away and
hopefully people will come and realize
these are not the Nazis you're looking
for you know we're just people who want
to have an interesting conversation
about culture and history and
immigration and take questions from the
audience that's gonna be a blast
yeah and people's fears will be proven
to be rather unfounded that's wishful
thinking because if they're not going to
stop calling ben shapiro with the
yarmulke on a nazi someone as
translucent as you and lauren southern
haven't got a shot so you're you're
still gonna be tagged with that one
don't bring the background no see here's
the thing though stephen is that what
i'm going to do this is my big plan
let me know what you think of it this is
my big plan oh wait this is yours this
is your final plan big this patented yet
it's my big plan there will be people
who are you know outraged and upset but
what I'm going to do you see is I'm
going to bring data reason evidence calm
conversation negotiation and debate and
it's gonna be a giant epicenter tidal
wave of healing that is gonna pass on
through the world and I'm going to
remain entirely undisciplined in the
outcome of my plan
so you're like a critical thinking Benny
Hinn I like it I think it's copyright
now yeah idea well there's always that
balance we were talking about where calm
and unless someone gets violent or
disruptive or calls to violence and
that's what we do to change my mind and
then the other side of that coin is
Crowder confronts where you know a
little bit dickish hey so you're good
you're squared away with that speaking
of hysteria what's been your view here
on Supreme Court did you have anyone you
were really rooting for in this in this
kind of race my only real disappointment
with the Supreme Court is that no one
announced my actual tour dates so just
because I know Trump meant to do that
like before announcing the Supreme Court
pick so let me go through go through the
tour dates I'm sorry where's the best
place for people to find these online if
they don't remember they don't have an
auditory memory so it's axiomatic dot
events axiomatic dot events you can go
get your tickets I think there's still a
few left melbourne friday 20th july
perth sunday 22nd of July
Adelaide Tuesday 24th of July Sydney
Saturday the 28th of July Brisbane
Sunday 29th of July and Auckland New
Zealand Friday the 3rd of August it's
gonna be a blast it's gonna be one of
these things like you know when the
police first first toured Canada ever
like 12 people in the club but everyone
in Canada claims to be those 12 people
just be one of the people who's there
you don't want to miss it this is true
yeah every everyone loves to claim that
they were dancin no not so much you kind
of became a fan when was the sting
afterwards and then yeah wears a t-shirt
if you were there I was into the cube
before loved cats man before love cat
exactly
I saw them open for Billy Joel and but
and I left before Billy Joel I don't
believe you okay so I was hoping they
were gonna actually open up Billy Joel
it's just like open him right
joël fan I know for some reason it's not
cool to be a Billy Joel fan but I was
when I grew up I loved Tom Jones and I
loved Billy Joel they were my guilty
pleasures until I decided I don't care
enough anymore I have enough money so
with this funny thing about Billy Joel
if you're a Billy Joel fan first of all
some of the best pipes in the business
and he's one of the guys whose voice is
only improved through the age but man
you got to be a patient guy what has it
been like a decade and a half or 17
years since his last new material I mean
that that guy he has a repetition
compulsion with his 80s stuff but you
gotta be patient for the new stuff man
well he said he'll never write music
better than he wrote in his 30s and so
he said I try and there are two
different schools of thought I mean you
know when you hear like Paul McCartney's
newest stuff you're killing all right
man you know time to pack it in so I
think yes where's who wasn't I saw I
think it wasn't Norah Jones and she was
doing this weird techno thing and I'm
not gonna play what you want me to play
but that's why we paid for a ticket so I
understand it but you're right he threw
his creative back out by the time he hit
36 mind-numbing drugs will do that to
you
so Supreme Court we got off track you've
been following us if you have anyone
specifically you were rooting for in
this in this turtle race I am a big one
for deferring to experts and there are a
few select people that I trust you would
be one of them also another person that
I trust in the media immigration is the
number-one issue
Ann Coulter is the number-one advocate
for a rational immigration policy so I
like whoever Ann Coulter likes and she
seems real keen on this guy and I hate
to say and I hate to abandon all
judgment for my own but it's like if
it's good enough Ann I think it's good
enough for just about anyone I
understand where you're coming from -
because when I voted in the first
Canadian election Stephen Harper I did
that was the first person I ever voted
for I remember I followed American
politics a whole lot more and I knew I
wasn't going to brush up on everything
regarding the parliamentary system I
couldn't know everything I didn't know
the NDP and the Liberals actually
supported defense of pedophile
pornography under the guise of art back
then I was like oh that's a red flag but
I remember I did have to ask some people
at that point whose opinions I really
respected and asked for some literature
so there's nothing wrong with that yeah
it seems like seems like either way
we're probably going to get a better
deal on immigration than we've been been
having but the left's hysteria
particularly hasn't been on immigration
if you've noticed it's been the roe v
wade conversation that women will cease
to exist I'm hearing as to your view on
this as I don't want to miss gender you
miss define you hear a Christian sort of
sympathetic atheist what's your point of
view on this landscape right now well
that's that's a big question I have
significant moral reservations about
abortion and it's chain this is a cliche
but nonetheless it's true and it's
happened to me Steven is that after you
become a father
sorry it ain't just a cluster of cells
it ain't just something hanging out
there like some moss in a cave you know
this is a potential human being with
jokes and thoughts and insights and
intelligence and reason this is like a
huge potential human being and so I have
big big reservations about it that
having been said at the same time
there's so much that would be cleared up
if we weren't forced to all pay for each
other you know like I mean I think drugs
should be legalized but at the same time
I don't want my taxes being jacked up to
pay for people who want to smoke weed
all day sit on their couch rather
because you know they can do that right
so I don't like the idea of just saying
abortion it's perfectly fine perfectly
legal you can go kill your babies and so
on and at the same time though if you
say well you can have all of this free
abortion and then I've got to pay for it
that's a big problem as well because you
know the destruction of families and the
absence of fatherhood and the lack of
responsibility and so on right so to me
it all comes down to like immigration
it's the welfare state I know if you
heard of these these guys these migrants
who got rescued by a boat that took them
back to Tunisia but they wanted actually
to get to the welfare state in Europe so
they threatened to behead the captain
and the crew you know as you do when you
rescued from sea I remember that last
scene in Titanic movie yeah it may have
got dropped from the movie when the
person who came to rescue Kate Winslet
she attempt to chew his head off with
their own teeth in fact it's just the
same Somali pirates say that's not they
he didn't pass a screen test they just
held that Somali pirate and reserved for
Captain I didn't know and now he's a
rom-com so if I'm not if I'm not forced
to people pay for people's bad decisions
then I'm find myself a lot more
open-minded to these bad decisions but
right now if you allow for if you if you
ban abortion they will of course be
to a short degree an increase in
illegitimate births it will probably
gear down over the long run as people
cuz consequences change people's
decisions yeah but forcing everyone else
to pay for that it's um it's it's a bad
scene it's a bit as I've seen and of
course they're they're well beyond that
milestone in Canada and Quebec where I'm
from is terrible 100 highest I think the
highest abortion rate in the
industrialized world if you were to rate
it as a country which it's not but we
kind of wish it were sometimes I guess
my question sex Oh Quebec it's kind of
weird too because Quebec went from like
4,000 children a woman down to nine
abortions and half a dog you know like
they just like can you find something in
the middle the Greets whomping the
planet in québécois and having no
children at all like something in the
middle would be fine how does an
abortion cost genuine question without
without insurance in Quebec or here here
in states genuinely I have no I know
what planet parent it's a few hundred
dollars it sound like that like good I
cap Nicole removed no it's not that
expensive no and they mostly deal in
cash only especially if you go to alley
number twelve so here's here's I guess
my question is more so because there
have been some people saying well
conservatives to just stay off social
issues completely in another clip which
I don't necessarily I don't disagree
with the idea that hey hit like you said
cut off the head of the dragon first the
giant welfare state so we're not paying
for it or I understand that being
tactful matters but I don't believe that
we should have been in social issues
certainly not if it involves and it's
not a social issue if you believe that
that is a person but as a Christian
sympathizing atheist what I find out
what I mention as far as your opinion is
they vase this argument on the idea that
we'll lose all libertarians and all non
Christian evangelicals if we have some
kind of a stance on abortion and the
more I've been encountering a lot of
atheists a lot of libertarian and the
more science progresses it seems that's
not the case and it's actually a winning
argument at least to put some
limitations on it well at least from the
cultural standpoint can we at least
understand that you know Michelle wolf
Sandy's saying god bless of abortion
that is a celebration of nihilus and
that is a celebration of death so even
if you are say okay well the woman
should have the right to terminate her
pregnancy even though the man has no
right to financially terminate his
involvement if you say that the woman
has it let's at least recognize it is a
terrible horrible thing it causes
depressed
it causes you know tragic this would
have been my child would have been five
you know like for anybody with a
conscience and abortion is a disaster
let's at least say okay if it's legal
it's legal but let's not celebrate this
killing of an unborn child let's at
least get to the point where we can say
this is a terrible terrible disaster
let's not celebrate it and let's do
everything we can to minimize its
recurrence and let's also recognize that
when women have 18 different forms of
birth control not including a dime a
dime is very cheap both the form of
birth control you put it between your
knees and you keep it there are you
getting pregnant yeah no it is by the
way it's not for a lack of education
today in 2018 my wife volunteers at a
crisis pregnancy center where they
actually do offer screenings they
actually do offer free ultrasounds they
actually do offer nannying nannying
services and job listings for single
mothers resources support for adoptions
they don't do any of those things at
Planned Parenthood but I think what you
just said is is right I mean shout your
abortion was the hashtag and I thinks I
think that's why opens the door to it
being a winning argument they're saying
celebrate abortion taxpayer-funded
period I don't think that conservatives
need to shy away from saying no this is
a really bad thing that has bad societal
ramifications we've gone too far
regardless of roe v-- wade but i do
think it'll be entering to see what
happens worried about you i'd say no i
just interesting to me how far the
pendulum has swung the other way it's
almost like I know it's a reaction to
for them to go from you know safe legal
in a rare I'm not saying for the baby by
the way but yeah going all the way to
celebrate like you know you got Lena
Dunham saying I wish I regret not having
them yeah that's a good that's crazy how
what was wasn't it it seems like your
reaction to something but I can't
pinpoint what it is because they've
gotten more and more leeway with them oh
I don't know I mean well certainly as
far as the you know that some of the
theories around population replacement
it's not that hard to figure out that
what's America had 50 million abortions
and 50 million immigrants you know
that's that's a clear you know scoop
something out and put something else in
you know the replace to tire you know oh
look we don't have enough people at
America hey we've got to import all
these people from the third world that's
not a great idea one of the big
solutions oh there's a wonderful free
market solution to the problem of
abortion even if it remains perfectly
legal one of the big problems is there's
no market for babies and so women can't
sell her baby I know
people are like oh that's terrible and
that's interesting because people react
to that like you're going to set up a
website called eBay B and and you know
sell them online and so on and people
say well that's terrible
that's terrible the baby gets to live in
what scenario is it terrible that the
parent that the baby gets to live
because you know ten percent of married
catholic couples are infertile have to
have big problems conceiving they
desperately want babies and so you have
people with a deficiency of fertility
even you have other people with an
excess of fertility let's have the
market close them off let's have people
pay to have other to get other people's
babies and it's like and if you report
by that then you have some idea how
appalling abortion is to other people
that's a that's a good analogy I don't
know I don't know where I line up on
selling babies I understand they were
neat I need to think about it there
certainly would need to be some some
markers in place to protect against your
question is what is Michelle wolf think
yes what is shocking candles I caught a
lot of flack for saying that I think you
should be able to sell your kidneys if
you want because I'm gonna haul a second
everyone's making money in this equation
the doctor is making money
the anesthesiologist making money the
guys getting the kidney the only one who
is the guy volunteering there's no
what's the incentive here unless it's my
uncle and my dad makes me so I feel if
you're actually getting sworn open you
should be making the most money in that
situation that no one else is getting
the guy who's bleeding out half on the
table the guy who's having someone go in
there with some Monty Python hack sorta
to carve out an essential piece of
innards I got no problem with that guy
making money all the people who aren't
getting okay make it money exactly it's
like the meat of the day it gets market
value okay we do have to get going again
where is the best place for people to
find your tour dates coming up in
Australia that sounds like a party and I
hope you're safe it's gonna be great
axiomatic dot events a couple of tickets
left there's some meet and greets you
can have dinner but Lauren and I we do
pros our private chats which is gonna be
great fun looking forward to meeting
everyone thanks a lot for your time
Stephen always a great pleasure to chat
absolutely that's okay you can follow me
at stefan molyneux we have to get going
we have to get going okay Jerry I needed
that you need to hear this music here
coming in and
[Music]
greetings America this week boy humans
let him into the live read
dollarshaveclub.com slurs crowd you can
get your free $5 it's not free - it's a
$5 replica it's not free it's not free
query this is line okay you get a
sampler kit and they have bobblehead
shampoo body wash and raises and they
have the balls to support this this
program which I'm unambitious but I
can't say because I don't have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm back in the panties again good for
the SunShot all right when do be cause
they'll be sweatin my balls back in the
panties again the panties some call me a
queer uppered [ __ ] where the quality's
good night and the pressures just right
back in the babies again Ranger panties
available ladder with crush opcom get
yours today
it's like tea bagging an angel
[Music]
have you actually seen a gorilla do this
you know I feel like it's false
advertisement I've seen it once I've
seen like I've seen a one like a scratch
I have but not the counterbalance oh
they do actually do that with tremendous
accuracy in velocity startling startling
almost one word today especially when
you're an old lady in a wheelchair
still the funniest video on the internet
basic visual abase fog is always a thing
I always wonder if you could train
somebody like Ted Brian Shawn and how
strong he is how insanely strong a
chimpanzee would he would embarrass him
if you could train a chimpanzee to
benchpress and if you can give a
chimpanzee red wine and xanax and the
remote like the wrong Club could be can
we arrange this I think I think pretty
sure it's a violation
all right all right but a brew got our
next guest a lot of a lot of a lot of
creditor listeners and Watchers out
there were saying I don't know they
didn't know exactly how this is going to
go they just were surprised that we were
having him on but we had been
communicating via direct message for a
while and he's he's got like six million
something subscribers on the YouTube
that's a lot video gaming last time I
played a video game I was telling him
was Medal of Honor online with the m1
carbine and go ping and the Germans
would come either stay fascinating ai
but you can follow my on the Twitter it
day he didn't Uggla t da i th I D en o
GL done ugly
I just got it wrong it's Gaelic it's
Gaelic and it's the same YouTube channel
mr. na mr. nog nog like now I'm getting
pain like how are you sir we first said
hi you overthought it man well I didn't
know we were in Ireland there's there's
Gary Gaelic road signs that it's it's
yeah do people stuff they only speak it
properly and like the güell talked where
it's only Irish there most people they
got like they can save their own name
and their age and that's it like it's
ready okay
very little kind of knowledge there they
know it's common people who seem
dangerous to make that exclusively the
road signs it would seem as though maybe
they should just know they got English
too they did we'd be screwed otherwise I
can't imagine listen mister dunno Glee
or buckaroo we'll just say from now on
glad to have you on the program
what
spurred this first off I know listen for
to go out there don't slander don't rake
his name through the mud because he's on
my show i he's not a crazy far right
winger to the right of Attila the Hun
like myself but why would you even
consider visiting us well personally
speaking like I watch especially when
the election kind of heated up a lot yes
I actually moved for a couple of months
to Los Angeles
I lived there a couple of months or a
year and then a couple of months here I
really like Los Angeles it's just I like
weird people I don't know why well
that's the place things you're not sure
some microscopic but all that kind of
stuff was heating up and that's kind of
what piqued my interest and kind of the
political sphere and whatnot so I just
kind of dabbled and I looked at
different sides and obviously one side
was yours and I well the main thing that
keeps me there is kind of like the humor
you know mix you mix it up you mix it up
which is this kept me kind of interested
yeah and just a mix of hero and
dishonesty that's that's if you read the
articles I'm glad we have you and would
you say that um because when we were in
Ireland let me say this we were in
Ireland a lot of people held sort of
conservative or traditionalist views but
not that they just hated conservative
Americans when they lined up quite a bit
I don't I think they have this
misconstrued notion about what we are do
you think there's some of that yeah I
don't think in my mind at least
personally I don't think a lot of people
even know the difference between
Democrat and Republican right if you ask
them yeah which which ladder leaning
probably majority would never clue right
so yeah I wouldn't really blame or if
they're mixing up kind of like their
perspectives and half another drunk but
politics you probably we did the show in
the pub the only drunk was a Scot and he
was he was he was drinking Budweiser and
he walked in and stole the show
because I don't remember correctly you
at least said some nice things about ben
Carson which being in Los Angeles I
thought
very very early on he did quite well and
like showing the statistics he was
growing a lot yeah but then he just
completely screwed up and I didn't know
he had that parrot of his personality at
the time that I you know I I was kind of
like really positive about him yeah it's
almost like sounds like he's he's not
created for the public sphere I feel
like he's you know he's more of an
industrial kind of guy yeah behind the
kind of desk or whatever but in terms of
people's faces and talk in public often
it seems like he kind of says things I
think it seems like he almost and here's
the thing I don't I don't think he like
really like he sabotage themselves to be
really honest I don't think there was I
mean do you think that it was a moment
where he screwed up I just think he
fizzled out I thought I think he was
like yeah I mean I've been ever instead
you know my my thing yeah I think he
just did I don't know if there was I
don't know was I think it was his lack
of lack of I guess information about
like Foreign Affairs and other stuff
like that I think like when they kind of
scrutinized him on certain things he
seemed weak right I think people saw
that and they kind of like moved on
basically yeah well you know it's
interesting you say that because I've
seen you know I look to come through
some of your tweets as we do research I
want any people who come on and I just
saw some very nice reasonable things
about dr. ben Carson I thought well
that's that's odd you know you don't see
that a whole lot and so I think because
yeah you know there's far-left and
there's there's this far right not so
much for her but there there's the left
and then there's far right I guess we
can say but um when you in this moment
in time two years ago you liked Ben Kerr
and you said some very kind things that
were reasonable but at that snippet in
time remember the left was trying to
paint him as an Uncle Tom racist invalid
[ __ ] and you're taking your life in
your hands in LA if you even say
actually I think he's okay what was that
a part of even if later on he didn't do
well in the election the way they
attacked him do you think that was a
part and maybe some of your evolution
where you're going home in a second this
this seems like a decent I don't think
that had much impact because I just
consider that noise in my opinion okay I
just considered noise so it's just like
I I kind of drown it out
so too like kind of getting more
interested
hmm I'll have to recollect a bit there
now I think I think and I think a reason
was I just didn't feel like he could one
as well I don't know I don't mean Ben
Carson sorry I mean I should have
clarified my question what what point
did you sort of start to I hate to use a
term like open your mind and kind of
take an interest in damn walk read
pilled
yeah no I don't want to do that because
didn't gave a bunch of peppe's coming
you're one of us Pet Sematary I know all
sides and the memes and outsides and
what the outside has to say about the
other but I would say I would say soon
after Trump became like the main
Republican nomination yeah it was
one-on-one versus Hillary and I think
then that's when I started asked like a
lot of questions because at that stage I
think most people who had a you know had
a skeptical view of both people like
they're neither of them are really
worthy of much kind of worship you know
right yeah they're not like the polished
Obama yeah you know so the bottom a very
obvious flaws and so when two people are
very obvious flaws you gotta ask
questions yeah then instead of just
ignoring the flaws and just gonna bond
so kind of at that point I don't my own
curiosity I didn't vote it was just
curiosity right what but so what would
you say I guess at that point sort of
having to look at the lesser of two
evils almost forced you to examine it
more yeah examine it more examine like
my conscience more and see what are the
things that really matter and what are
the things that are blown out of
proportion in yada-yada-yada because
obviously it's it's it's a war of words
right there and what really matters to
you like I noticed a lot of newer sort
of I guess non liberals let's just use
that white umbrella free speech are a
big thing is that a big component yeah
yeah free speech is fairly important I
think like like a good structural
economic kind of philosophy is really
important and I think I think kind of
individual rights is a pretty big one
too you
and then that's it and then like yeah I
think like I don't like governments that
are extremely controlling of aspects of
people's lives so I don't like that at
all that always goes downhill so
basically a government set up to easily
control you know the the people that
it's supposed to serve sure it's that's
that's that's probably the main one roll
rolling it see yes exactly congratulate
you like America and in 2018 no other
governments how is this real what's the
reaction like in the gaming community
talk about it with people at all when
you're when you're doing the UM I tend
to find a game in community actually
kind of veers more towards like more
towards economic values like most my
friends they they don't care too much
they like the tax breaks yeah they're
all business
businessmen them's owe a lot of money in
the gamer community I'm guessing it's
like this minecraft I don't have enough
mattresses to stuff it hopefully
hopefully Trump's cuts come through I am
getting reigned buddy so so back that's
kinda like the man the man thing I've
kind of noticed at least from guys and
it's a heavily male community have no
jobs from guys as well really gamers are
looking for job there you go let it
never be well and they care about cos
they care about stuff like that know
exactly and I remember a lot there was a
big attack on the gaming community from
from obviously the feminists left for a
while and I oh yeah there's some like
good things not just that but the whole
industry right was saying it's two guys
and trick you see that with late night
comedy they said it's two male centric
and don't just look at the hosts look at
the viewership the viewership of late
night has been predominantly male
because they like to watch comedy at
night and women tend to like watch to
watch other things there's nothing wrong
with that I don't think there need to be
yeah that's just it's just feminine and
masculine side of things yeah as it
relates to content i have noticed though
i don't know if you've noticed with the
gaming community it does seem to be
leaning we're seeing a swing and I
wonder if it's his temporary with with
Donald Trump like you mentioned kind of
Trump Hillary or if it's almost like a
shift between sort of Napster in the
music industry if it's that monumental
where it seemed
like a lot of young men who at one point
would have been very far left out of a
sense of rebellion are becoming more
right leaning out of a sense of the
counterculture particularly with guns
particularly with free speech and
particularly I think like a lot and a
lot of gamers already edgy yeah and to
be edgy it's difficult to be edgy and
leftist it's why are you difficult to be
tell that to every late-night host on
television ever right now all of every
single one of them like I'm edgy don't
Christian suck yeah oh I'll make a lot
of variety jokes obviously some stuff
you stay off to kind of you know knock
in too much hot water but um you know
yeah I find that I think I think gaming
will always be very centrist more
leaning towards the right and the reason
why is because majority of games are
extremely practical and efficient okay I
give to make the best out of what you're
doing all the time it's a good point and
so that that doesn't really go with
socialist unfortunately for socialist
actually the idea of practical
efficiency and socialism they usually
what like I'm one of the major kind of
points when I know it's like government
is hugely lacking in efficiency is when
I went to got a visa and it was like it
was like five hour wait to talk to
someone for like a minute and yeah I
mean it's like and everyone's just
sitting doing nothing and the line so
slow and you got to go through like four
or five I'm just like yeah the red tape
there's so much behind the scenes that
slows things down and I think that's why
gaming is more more centrist than
anything else
I was lost time I went to the DMV it was
this lady who was sitting there was
nothing to do the only thing she was
working on was her diabetes and she
couldn't even she couldn't get to me I
think sound guy ready to come and bring
me something I don't because I had a
license
I had a proof of citizen I had my birth
certificate and I had my tax return and
they said it wasn't enough that I needed
my actual social security card my social
security card my number is on my tax
returns like that says tax ID number
it's
and their believe anymore I had to go
back a week later that's a good point
gaming by definition kind of like sports
is entirely results-oriented
equal-opportunity sure anyone can play
the game
you cannot ensure equal results and I
have noticed that in any field where
it's hyper ly competitive and it's
really tough to tip the scales as far as
the results you tend to shuffle out some
and as you get toward the upper echelon
there are more right-leaning Peter also
a chance that it's due to gaming is a
community sort of event in a lot of ways
but it's also very much an individualist
event yeah especially historically yeah
I agree
I saw the wizard with the power glove
Fred Savage do you think there's truth
to what you say in there is he people
want to go where I think very monthly
yeah definitely because there's a
variety of games like there's a lot of
individual games where you have to pump
hours and hours and hours into the game
and you know that that brings a lot of
like personal attachment yeah and so I
think there was like a particular I
don't know the name of it it was like
trying triangular or something like it
was trying something but it was like
this weird philosophy of politics
created in like the 1920s by like I
think it was some holder and and there's
some there's some monks or something oh
the triangular no you're talking about
the Illuminati that's that's Furby I
know like a big part of its philosophy
is small businesses yes like how to like
give like and build up the working and
middle classes to have a big amount of
small businesses well if you're looking
to it I guess I know you're said you're
interesting all sides um you know I'd
recommend reading reading Smith Adam
Smith you that's guy had meant to
determine the invisible hand that
determines markets we always talk about
Hayek we talk about Karl Marx and talk
about Lenin we talk about today Noam
Chomsky I think Thomas soul is up there
but Smith is really great baseline
reading it's simple it's easy to
understand he's a European so there you
go you guys can claim that one you know
it's not just soccer and I highly
recommend but hey listen we do have to
get going
the you channels can you say it so that
I don't miss pronounce it here oh yeah
sure ah hey Donald look I wasn't gonna
get that in a million years thanks so
much for cutting
you back if there's anything specific
and of course I apologize immediately
for the blowback that you'll receive for
even talking with us I won't get any
negative stuff oh I'm very positive
about that
you gotta go and wrap this show up in a
nice bow oh there's a music
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to wild at large on the Nature
Network narrated by Jasper plug all the
business one of nature's most beautiful
creatures and in one of its frequent
twists of irony
also its most deadly weighing in at over
my lord that grizzly bear is humongous
are you seeing this yes just occupy us
but no I mean really I don't think I've
ever seen a land mammal outside of the
elephant but they're known aggressive
this animal is clearly a monster I
wonder what would happen if you put this
grizzly bear in an arena with a male
silverback gorilla I don't think that's
legal Jasper just keep going with the
Lions no I mean we have some budget here
at wild it larger I really think that if
we could sip that up if we could work
with the zoos and get a male grizzly
bear and a silverback gorilla and just
let them go to town I really think
that'd be something to have a despot
just do the lines well I sure think our
view was we're gonna kick out stay tuned
for more wild applause on the Nature
Network narrated by Jasper
[Music]
I'm good I'm the accurate recreation of
the physicality of water with the I
realized one everywhere I see cuz cuz
blue because when I was gone for the
foot no no no no your shirt right I was
at a pool and I was at a fat kid always
wear the t-shirt and there's no said he
kept me kept going with no you ever done
jumping jacks in a cold pool it feels
like it's going up you're being whole
it's not a lie
first I would ever think about doing
jumping jacks in swimming pool and if I
did and that happened once I would stop
how did you meet jacks did you do it
like five pounds right yeah by the way
at that point it's just internal
cleansing I have a correction to make
Richard painter not state Senate no he's
going he's going for the he's going for
gold yes going for gold he's going for
gold let us know we've talked about by
the way thanks for I guess what's his
name I don't know I remember forget not
died he died hey denovi de no-go de
nobler there no glove no glue no glue
died he didn't no glue
dammit diets we'll fix that impose very
nice it's just I'm not good with that
I don't speak Gaelic no no none of us do
you think what traders gonna win it's
tradition well I think we talked about
this earlier this week four people are
not mug Club members we are we are
considering and let us know in the
comments section if you'd like that we
are considering going to cover Richard
painters actual Senate debate it would
be press row with all the Minnesota I
don't know their main papers I don't
know if it's the st. Paul hair I have no
idea and us if you can I think it would
be worthwhile I want to get I want him
to win if you can put because I wasn't
remember him but if it on the ballot if
you could put Richard dumpster fire or
two painter
I think he's entering the ring we have
Richard they're just renewing the season
at that point he has a very looping left
and a right it depends on the
circumstances she goes left in with his
mouth I don't know you had a good point
actually we were talking with this
during the break yeah I was thinking
about this a lot with the vote anything
and people say oh you know vote vote
vote for winning issues and I was
thinking like I get what they're saying
yes but but I was thinking like if you
are not voting through the prism of
your morality if it's
based on Christian Judeo values or
whatever it is what are you running for
Sharia
oh great stuff there I can't even that
compatible with the concert easy huh
yeah my mom okay well if you're already
voting pragmatically like what are you
doing how do you feel good about
yourself at the end the night like what
is it why even do it at all yeah I mean
I understand having a winning path to
achieving your going okay this is in the
first certainly as you spend other
people's time how you try to convince
them of right like if you're a great but
if you're a boxer and you've got a great
overhand right you need to set it up
with a jab I understand that but if
you're just going in there and you're
running away the whole time why are you
in the fight and right now with abortion
there's so much misinformation that
there's so much bad science going on
yeah that I think that's it's a very
clear open path to talk to people
because some people it's not it's not a
long you don't need a hour long it's not
a very long conversation to really reach
people it's a very short conversation
about those putting some very pointed
questions I think I think it's unpopular
it's one of our lesser popular changed
my mind and a big reason is a lot of
people just uncomfortable the topic of
abortion yeah but they are the ones that
the probably most productive ones yeah
where people goes oh okay alright I
understand that now we had several
people say I hadn't thought about it
before I'm gonna go home and do my
research would you bring out the cherami
like okay it's draw the line draw the
line and you know what I realized though
was the left to kind of get to my yeah I
don't know if you like closing thoughts
or something this is something branded
somewhere our branded somewhere outside
closing thoughts no spin zone my mind
speaking my mind shooting straight so I
don't know just my last thought of the
day I don't know what someone's gonna
send us a trademark violation let's love
the days from let it be incorporated
damn it the left has been doing what if
I'm gonna give you one piece of advice
and this is this is they've been taking
the easy door for a long time culturally
after roe v-- wade
they haven't been going out to educating
people know there are times where they
could go out there and if they really
wanted to push the boundaries yeah Jimmy
if they wanted to push the boundaries
and they wanted to talk about they could
go through the hard door but instead
like wow let's just rest on these wall
laurels and this is something that I've
been thinking about a lot this is why I
always have reservations about about any
kind of messages or advice to anyone
that like right now is avoiding conflict
a lot of people like I wouldn't want
this to escalate let's avoid conflict or
why did a message one time where we
talking I was talking about being
disciplined about rest because you look
at Brian Shaw he talked about that
George st. Pierre a lot of high-level
people but I'm all I've always a little
a little bit unsure footed when
discussing those because anytime you
offer advice where someone can use as an
excuse to go through the easy door I get
uneasy this is what I mean but sometimes
we talked about this sometimes the easy
door to walk through right is the right
option and that's perfectly fine you
don't always have to make things hard on
yourself training hard for example
working hard isn't always training hard
or smart I get it but before you even
make your decision here's what's most
important always leave that hard door
open that's what's important and that's
why I don't want to say if I tell people
hey listen avoid conflict at all costs
generally that's right but you really
have to explain it because most people
are terrified of conflict even even when
it's necessary and so if it gives
someone okay great close the hard door
of conflict when it comes to protecting
what's worthy of Priene being protected
if I say hey listen what's really
important is not only how hard you work
but rest sometimes we go okay rest is
what's most important and they close the
hard door on hard training or it could
be work it could be your family good
example of this recently I'm talking
about this with the left you see it
they've constantly walked if they have a
majority look at Barack Obama with
hizmet he couldn't get anything done he
couldn't and they're getting so much
done right now Republicans because they
have been fights like training with a
weighted vest they know what it's like
to march on through that hard door when
they've been vilified for years good
example of this personally I saw some
people recently from my past my age way
I hadn't seen in a long time let me
preface this I'm no prize peg I get it
okay but these people had really let
themselves go and do you ever have you
ever met people like that like your age
from college from high school and you
wonder like how it's one of the things
where I look at round and my parents
friends growing up I'm like how that
happened then now I'm seeing the
evolution of my friends I'm like oh
that's how it happens right I see it now
like you were the skinny hot kidding and
now wow yeah your identity in the end
maury povich you are I don't know what
you a father of something
some people get a rough shake so I want
to be clear I'm talking I'm talking
person about a big group of people
I remember what they looked like or what
they acted like I remember what they
were like in that same time period you
know me I had knee surgery I wrote
issues almost had to have it new but
I've had some issues that I've run into
certainly issues where I've seen people
give up and just oh yeah you know you
see a lot we see with some women who
have children you know you've never had
a baby your kids in college you're 900
pounds like this is ditte this is it's
not the same thing I get it everyone's a
little bit different but we are talking
about generalities here because you have
to and you know you've heard the term
I've talked about talk about how it's
death by a thousand cuts it's actually
it's really death by a thousand hard
doors closed it's it really it starts
with alpha I'm tired I don't feel like
going to the gym today boom you close
that door it starts with a screw screw
the die for the weekend it starts
without finish that report for my boss
later I'll take the trash out for my
wife with it I'll rub my wife's feet
later I'll take my kid to play play at
the park later into bang bang bang all
of a sudden 10 years down the line
you're a 32 year old person you're 22
year old self wouldn't even recognize
him you wonder how it happened at every
single point there was the easy door to
walk through and the hard door and
sometimes again the easy door is the
right door don't get me wrong but you'll
never even know it if you always close
the hard door before you even take a
gander for there to be a right there has
to be a wrong okay there needs to be
contrast so if you're just waltzing
through easy door after door you don't
even know what the hard door looks like
anymore and you know what the worst part
about that is and this is why I'm always
reserved about giving advice that could
even allow someone to think of this as
an option my good friend shale son and
not good friend but friend he talked to
me once about a sports psychologist and
I've spoken with this person and I said
you know it's really it's it's
hyperbolic people say failure is not an
option
and he said you know most failure is
always an option it's actually the most
readily available and easily available
option and that was important for me to
know and if you closed the hard door
non-stop you don't even recognize it
anymore the saddest part about it is and
all I'm saying is make sure it's an
option on the table not saying you have
to go through the hard door every time
but if it's not even an option the worst
thing is you surely have
hope of ever finding out what's behind
it and that's why I'm always careful
about giving advice it sounds nice that
sounds virtuous no conflict I'm a
pacifist let's make sure that we all get
along let's not go after row V let's
pick winning issues I get it sometimes
you take the path of least resistance
sometimes you gotta have a plan but you
can't close the hard door and leave the
hard options off of the table for your
whole life because at a certain point
you've just lived a coward's life see
you next week
[Music]